- [Instructor] Hey, this
is Kim from Khan Academy
and today I'm learning about Article five
of the U.S. Constitution,
which describes The
Constitution's amendment process.
To learn more about Article
five, I talked to two experts,
professor Michael Rappaport,
who is the Darling Foundation
professor at the University
of San Diego School of Law,
where he also serves as the director
of The Center for the Study
of Constitutional Originalism
and David Strauss, who's the Gerald Ratner
distinguished service professor of law
at the University of Chicago Law School
and author of The Living Constitution.
Professor Strauss, Article
five provides this process
for amending The Constitution,
can you take us through
that process a little bit?
How does it work?
- [Professor Strauss]
Well the quick description
of the process is it's really hard,
it's really hard to
amend The Constitution.
There are actually a couple
of different processes
that are laid out in Article five
but only one has ever been used.
An amendment starts in Congress
and two thirds of each house of Congress,
two thirds in House of Representatives
and two thirds of the Senate
has to approved the amendment
and then it goes to the states
and three quarters of the states
have to approve the
amendment, so you have to have
a really strong consensus in order
to get The Constitution changed that way.
- [Kim] So, Professor Rappaport,
take us through this process
of amending The Constitution.
Why did the framers set it up this way?
- [Professor Rappaport] The framers gave
a good bit of thought to coming up
with an amendment process
because they recognized
that The Constitution might
need to be changed over time
either 'cause there were problems with it
that weren't anticipated
or because circumstances
or values changed, so, there are two steps
to the amendment process, for an amendment
to go into The Constitution to become part
of The Constitution it has to
be both proposed and ratified.
On the proposal side,
the Congress can propose,
alternatively, a proposal can come from
the action of the state legislatures,
so, two thirds of the
state legislatures say
we'd like to have a
Constitutional Convention
propose an amendment, so,
there's two parts to that,
obviously, the the state legislatures
have got to want it and
then you get the calling
of a Constitutional Convention.
Okay, that's the proposal side,
there's also the ratification side,
which is a little bit simpler.
You need three quarters of the states
to ratify a Constitutional amendment
and they can ratify it either
through the actions of
the state legislatures
or the actions of state conventions,
which are special bodies
which would be elected
in order to decide one
question, whether or not
to ratify that proposed
Constitutional amendment.
- [Kim] This is fascinating, so,
I actually had no idea
about the two thirds
of the state legislatures being able
to propose a Constitutional amendment.
How often does that happen?
- [Professor Rappaport]
It has never occurred
throughout our history,
although, a couple of times
there were actions taken to
sort of move in that direction
but we've never actually had
a Constitutional Convention
that has proposed any amendments.
It's important to go into why the framers
would have set up the
system the way they did.
The most usual situation
is for the Congress
to propose the amendments
and that's happened
in all of the 27 amendments
which have been ratified
to become part of our Constitution
but what happens if the
Congress is the problem?
What happens if the
Congress is usurping power
or they're standing in the way of changes
that are important or
they need to be reformed?
You can't count on the
Congress to wanna reform itself
so what they did was to have
this alternative mechanism
which would bypass the Congress
and that alternative mechanism
was the Constitutional Convention,
so the state legislatures
proposed, applied for,
and the separate entity, the
Constitutional Convention,
makes a proposal, so
they were quite explicit
in discussing this, that they wanted this
as an alternative to the Congress.
- [Kim] So was this on purpose
that they made it very difficult
to amend The Constitution?
- [Professor Strauss] Well
it sure seems like it.
Now, of course, we don't know back then
what they had in mind,
whether they thought,
"Well, the House, the Senate, the states,
"they'll sort of be all run
by the same kind of people
"and they'll kind of agree on things."
Maybe they thought
that, we just don't know
but whatever they were
thinking, what they gave us
was a very difficult
process to get through.
- [Kim] So, how long
was it from the period
when The Constitution was first ratified
to the first amendment to The Constitution
beyond the Bill of Rights?
- [Professor Rappaport] Okay, so,
the first 10 amendments
were ratified in 1791
and then, just a mere three years later,
we had the 11th amendment.
- [Professor Strauss] There
was an 11th amendment in 1798
to correct really kind
of a technical problem
that the Supreme Court did something
that the framers really
didn't anticipate it would do,
didn't want it to do,
and the 11th amendment
was adopted to correct that.
The 12th amendment was adopted in 1804,
after the, really, kind of a disaster
in the election of 1800,
when there was a tie
in the electoral college,
the framers had not foreseen
the rise of political parties
and political parties made the system
for electing the president
they had given us
very difficult to work with
but then there was nothing.
That was 1804, then there was nothing
until after the Civil War
and after the Civil War
there were three amendments,
then nothing again,
really, until the progressive
era in the early 20th century
when there were, again,
a bunch of amendments
and then after then, things
have sort of tailed off.
So, we really see these kind
of waves in our history.
- [Kim] What do you think
brings those waves on?
Why are there some eras
where there are lots
of Constitutional amendments
and then other eras
when there's nothing?
- [Professor Strauss] Well, Kim,
here I'm gonna say something
I think some people
will disagree with but, you
know, but I think it's right
and that is that I don't think the process
of amending The
Constitution has really been
the way we actually change it.
I think what happens is just because
the amendment process is so difficult,
we've worked out other
ways of changing things
and so amendments come along, sometimes,
because a change has already happened
and people decide, "Well, let's put it
"in The Constitution
just so we can kinda have
"official recognition of it."
But a lot of time changes happen
and they are a little
bit too controversial
to get into The Constitution
but they seem pretty solid
and pretty secure, so, we just don't,
I guess it's fair to say,
don't bother to amend
The Constitution or don't
wanna go through the process
of amending The Constitution.
- [Professor Rappaport]
Very often peoples' values
may change or they may differ
from what's in The Constitution
and it may take a time or circumstances
may finally occur that crystallize this
desire to change The Constitution
and all of a sudden the
opportunity is there
and people can suddenly pass
a Constitutional amendment.
It's only gonna occur
during certain circumstances
especially when there's
strong support for it.
- [Kim] Very interesting,
yeah, so it's unlikely
that we're gonna have a
Constitutional amendment
anytime in the near future.
When was the last
Constitutional amendment?
- [Professor Rappaport] So,
the simple answer to that
was in 1971 we got the 26th amendment
that was both proposed
and then, remarkably,
it's an all time record,
proposed and ratified in
three months and eight days
and that was the amendment
that guaranteed the right
to vote of 18 year olds.
- [Kim] Ah, right, so
sort of as a response
to the Vietnam War?
- [Professor Rappaport] Yes, yes
but there actually has been
one additional amendment,
the 27th amendment, right,
so why isn't that the most recent one?
Well, here's the funny thing about it,
the 27th amendment was proposed as part
of the original Bill of Rights in 1789,
so this amendment was proposed in 1789,
ratified in 1992, so it took 202 years.
- [Kim] What you're saying,
what's the 27th amendment about?
- [Professor Rappaport]
That has to do with
congressional salary increases.
It basically says if Congress
wants to raise its own salary,
the increase can't take effect
until the next election,
so it basically give the
voters a chance to say,
"Hey, we don't like what you did,
"we're gonna vote you out of office
"for increasing your salary."
- [Kim] So, one thing
that strikes me about
Article five or just the
fact that the founders
included an amendment process altogether,
it seems very humble and farsighted
to include a way for the document itself
to evolve in a way, do you think
that the framers
approached The Constitution
with the idea that there
were things in the future
that they just wouldn't
be able to anticipate?
- [Professor Strauss] They had before them
and were acutely aware of a history
in which efforts to establish
governments had failed
and they were really
trying to work with that
and make sure they
didn't do the same thing
so they knew what a hard
job they were embarking on
and they made it clear, I mean,
there's a famous passage in
which James Madison said,
"Look, we know a lot of these provisions
"that we're writing in The Constitution
"their meaning is
unclear and their meaning
"will have to be history's liquidated."
Which is to say, people have to figure out
what this means because we
know what we're giving you
is unclear in some
ways, so, yes absolutely
they knew there were things
they could not anticipate.
The framers themselves
weren't in agreement
on what freedom of speech means, you know,
some of them enacted and voted for
and got enacted laws
that restricted speech
in ways that we would
find intolerable today,
we'd say they violate the first amendment
but here you have some of the guys
who drafted the first amendment
voting for those laws.
- [Kim] So, near the end of Article five,
there's this kind of
long-winded clause that says,
"No amendment which may
be made prior to the year
"one thousand eight hundred and eight
"shall in any manner affect
the first and fourth clauses
"in the ninth section
of the first article."
Now, if I'm cross
referencing this correctly,
what they're really saying here is,
you can't make amendments about slavery,
so why is this here and why are they
talking around it so obliquely?
- [Professor Rappaport] The
interesting thing about this
is what do they do, they basically said,
for 20 years there's not
going to be any amendments
that are going to speak to the slave trade
and The Constitution is
very, let us say shy,
about using the term slavery
or referring to slavery,
it actually never refers
to the term slave,
there's a variety of thoughts
about what was going on
but one very common view about this is
that The Constitution was sort
of a little bit embarrassed,
that the framers were a
little bit embarrassed,
or at least some of the framers
were embarrassed about it
and so they didn't wanna
make reference to it too explicitly.
- [Professor Strauss] They might've been
a little bit worried about
what the verdict of history
would be, so, they knew on some level
this sort of immorality of slavery
but there it is, right
there in Article five
and there are other places
in The Constitution too
where they don't use the
word but what they're doing
is protecting slavery.
And they did add these
amendments to The Constitution
about slavery and about, as you say,
equal citizenship and
voting but, you know,
the 14th amendment
providing equal citizenship,
that was pretty much
nullified in most respects
for a large part of our history,
states found a way to get around that.
The 15th amendment was also something
that was just not very effective
in preventing African Americans
from being denied the vote
and, yes, there are
provisions in The Constitution
that are there and you can evoke them
and you can rely on them
but if you just look at
the text of The
Constitution, I think you get
a misleading impression
about how The Constitution
in our history has actually worked.
- [Kim] This is a very good point
because I think one of the
hardest things for students
of U.S history to understand is
how is it possible that
after the 14th amendment
was passed, things like Jim Crow happened
and I guess the answer is The Constitution
is only in force if it's enforced.
- [Professor Strauss] Yeah,
Kim, that's exactly right.
It's words on a page, you know,
the text is fine, it can
say all the right things
but the institutions and the popular will
have to be in place to make
something of those fine words.
- [Kim] Interesting, so how do you think
our government might be different
if The Constitution didn't include
this amendment process?
- [Professor Strauss] I
don't think it would've been
that different just because
Article five gives us
such a hard process to go through
just because it's so hard
to amend The Constitution,
we figured out other ways
to change The Constitution
in practice, even if the
words on the page are the same
and I think if there were no Article five,
we would've found a way to get to
where wanted to get to as a country
by those needs, by legislation,
by presidential action,
by Supreme Court decision,
and just by the people
in their lives saying,
"You know, we need to
go in this direction,
"we need to go, say, in the
direction of women's equality."
And, by the way, there's no amendment
giving women equal rights either
but that's where we've gotten to
and I think that would've been the pattern
if there were no formal amendment process.
- [Professor Rappaport]
There's a second way
in which you can have
Constitutional change,
which is you could simply say,
"Alright, this Constitution
was pretty good for awhile,
"it's now outlived its usefulness,
"let's have a new Constitution."
That would seem like a very
radical, big thing to do,
virtually no on proposes
that at the federal level
but in the states, lots
of states have changed
their constitutions, not simply passed
a Constitutional amendment,
but just gotten rid of
a whole constitution
and adopted a new one.
That's happened many times and, so,
if we didn't have a
Constitutional amendment process,
it's quite possible that that's exactly
what we would've seen
at the federal level.
- [Kim] Wow, this is really fascinating
because we really think a lot about
what the framers intended, you know,
for certain amendments,
for example, you know,
freedom of speech, freedom of religion,
what did they really mean by those things
but if we had just kind of
every now and again said,
"Okay, we're done with that,
let's do a new Constitution,"
we wouldn't necessarily have that debate,
we'd just say, "Okay, this is
what we meant at the time."
- [Professor Rappaport]
Famously Thomas Jefferson said,
"Oh, you know, it's
really not right to have
"a Constitution that's
going to continue over time
"and bind future generations and, so,
"we ought to have a new
Constitution every 19 years
"when there's a new generation."
And his close friend, James Madison,
had to disagree with
him and basically said,
"Look, I understand why you're saying that
"but you also have to realize
the incredible disruption
"that would cause every 20 years,
"people wouldn't be able to
rely on the existing rights
"that are in The Constitution
'cause they would know
"in a certain period of time
new ones would be enacted."
We had that debate,
Madison won in the sense
that the U.S. Constitution
is supposed to last
for a long-term period,
there's no 20 year limit on it,
and one of the things
that's been beneficial
for the United States as a result of that
is that we've inherited
these Constitutional rights
that people have a lot of reverence for.
- [Kim] So, we've learned
that there are two ways
to amend The Constitution,
through Congress
or through a special
Constitutional Convention
called by the states, either way,
adding an amendment to The Constitution
is really difficult to do, so much so,
that the American people have only
in special circumstances used
a Constitutional amendment
to affect social or political change.
To learn more about Article five,
visit the National Constitution Center's
interactive Constitution
and Khan Academy's resources
on U.S. government and politics.